but peter great to see you as always
we've had some fun so far a little
spirited jameis winston discussion let's
see if we can have a spirited tom brady
discussion
hey look you know i somebody sent me a
a video from nfl network yesterday
saying hey here's why robert kraft
did what he did and here's why the
patriots agreed to it and i'm thinking
to myself
it's february 10th
four weeks ago
i interviewed kraft and he explained why
he did what he did what what what is
this
what do you mean here's why he did what
he did i got an interview with kraft i'm
looking at it right now
anyway whatever but i think the biggest
thing that ends up happening in cases
like this
when when tom brady you know a mega star
is going to go somewhere else
everybody in our business sort of has to
provide this content and has to give
their take on it and i understand the
way it is but i don't think very much
has changed mike in the last month uh
last five weeks really when tom brady uh
on that night in in foxborough it
basically stood at the podium
and said i'm gonna play football
somewhere next year i just don't know
where
yeah and nobody knows where and look i
don't even know if he knows where at
this point the question is when will he
know when will the patriots know when
will the rest of us know and the the the
whole point is this by the time free
agency opens
it there's a chance it's going to be
too late there's a chance that he'll
know where he's going to go the patriots
need to know if he's coming back peter
because they need to find somebody else
unless they're just going to hand the
ball to jared stidham right there's an
unprecedented array of veteran options
available that could be evaporating
quickly once the legal tampering window
opens on march 16. so
everyone involved in this needs to know
yes or no is he coming back to new
england before that march 16 window
opens after that that's when it gets a
little bit interesting and we touched on
this last hour
can tom brady really pull off a reggie
white
type of a free agency tour remember
reggie white the first big free agent he
was exempted from the franchise tag
because he's one of the name plaintiffs
in the
in the uh anti-trust lawsuit that paved
the way for true free agency at least as
true as it's ever going to be in the nfl
and he went from city to city and town
to town and god told him to sign with
the packers so he eventually did can tom
brady really pull that off because
you're going to have teams saying hey
tom we need to know what you're going to
do because we got somebody else lined up
and he's going to go somewhere else
right brady's the first domino and it's
a big giant domino that's going to help
figure out where all these other guys
land could he really pull off making uh
and wouldn't that be the ultimate power
move peter making all these teams wait
for him to decide what he's gonna do
before all these other dominoes begin to
fall
you know 26 years ago next month mike i
was on the plane with reggie white and
his agent jimmy sexton and and also a
friend of reggie white's harry galbraith
who was a guard that was the reggie
white free agency tour and we went to
cleveland uh he went to green bay i got
off the plane went to dallas
uh and you know he he toured everything
and i'll never forget
in sports illustrated when i wrote this
big story about basically the reggie
sweepstakes we did sort of an ingenious
thing with the cover we had to be one of
those fold out covers
and you could cut out with scissors the
uniform there were all these uniforms
with number 92 on it and you could cut
out the uniform of the team that you
felt he was going to sign with which was
your guess you know they had the 49ers
and the browns and you know and the
packers and washington and all these
teams and then you could put whatever
you want on the cover with reggie white
it was a riot
but
that was huge in those days and and you
know mike when you were saying that
this thought occurred to me
what if tom brady
who knew
that his tom vs time documentary with
gotham chopra which was so incredibly
good
so well done so inside
what if he knows how good that was
and what if he wants to do it again
and what if he tells teams listen
i'm going to talk to you and i'm going
to have this little courting period and
i'm going to go around to see all these
different teams
but and you know maybe the cameras don't
go into the meetings
but i'm just and look i have no idea and
i kind of doubt he would do it
but i'm saying that's what i thought
about when you said could there be this
free agency tour remember the grainy
footage of peyton manning
you know back in 2012 when he was behind
a gate about 200 yards away in tempe
arizona at the cardinals complex and you
see him seeing him out there with ken
wisen on just having a conversation oh
look peyton's talking to wizanon you
know for a while that was the biggest
story in sports so
i don't know what he'll do i don't know
what his people will do
but again you asked me the over under a
teams that i'll meet with and i think
it's over 1.5
and you know i said under at the time
because i thought this would all be
figured out ahead of time but as you
explain and as i remember the full depth
and breadth of the reggie white free
agency tour tom brady was 16 years old
at the time probably reading the sports
illustrated article that you wrote with
that foldout pro hoping that maybe he'd
come to the 49ers tom brady's favorite
team growing up and then his top rival
for the entire time of his career had
that red carpet treatment everywhere he
went they lined up out the door for
peyton manning who was coming off of
four neck surgeries peter they still
couldn't get enough of peyton manning
you combine those two
uh
and you look at how tom brady has has
behaved the last month and i'm not
passing judgment i'm not saying he's in
the wrong here i mean how if you've got
the juice if you've got the power and
you've waited 20 years to get to this
point and this is part of your of the
beginning of the end of your career if
you can start the final few years of
your career with an unprecedented free
agency extravaganza
where you do visit multiple teams where
you do take cameras with you where it
makes reggie white and peyton manning
look like small potatoes there's going
to be a strong temptation to do it
right
yeah
well i mean i just remember tom versus
time
and i just you know to me
it was like curvier enthusiasm where
every week i'm on my i'm on you know
pins and needles waiting for the next
episode you know and and i was that's
the way i was with the tom vs time thing
it was so good so timely so interesting
because it just showed sides of brady
that you just never saw before because
he never let a camera in
and and i just feel like and again i
have no idea
what is going to happen
but i just think that brady is kind of a
modern guy when it comes to that way a
modern communicator
and when he owned his own content in the
tom vs time thing
i mean it worked out pretty well for him
and i think it changed the image that a
lot of people had of him
and so peter i i think that what we have
here and this has been a far more useful
discussion than i ever would have
envisioned but when you consider his
history
nfl history
his rivalry with peyton manning and
everything that we've seen like so much
is kind of hiding in plain sight with
this there's two phases yeah is he gonna
go back to the patriots that's phase one
i think it's a practical matter
that's the ship that has to sail before
march the 16th
you either sign with the patriots
or you embark on the reggie white peyton
manning free agency tour i don't think
the patriots are still in play once the
boat's out of the harbor do you agree
with me on that
probably probably but i can i i'm just
gonna say this mike
i don't think in this particular case
that anything is set in stone but i do
have a pretty good feeling that we'll
probably get to march 12th or 13th and
know if there's any chance he's going to
go back to the patriots
and and it's been reported you've
mentioned this before on the program
adam schefter said that the patriots
want to know before free agency begins
because that that's when and and it's
not the start of free agency it's march
16 the legal tampering period because
what happens i mentioned this before but
you need to understand this folks what
happens is teams will start calling
agents immediately they've got their
list of positions where they're looking
for players they have their ranking one
through however many and they call the
first guy and they say here's our offer
for your client yes or no i need to know
right now why do you need to know right
now because we're moving on to the next
guy if you say no before that guy agrees
to terms with someone else that's how
quickly it all moves and the patriots if
they're gonna have to replace tom brady
again unless they're fine with jared
stidham if the float chart for new
england peter is very simple tom brady
yes
then we have him tom brady no it's jared
stidham they could wait for tom brady if
that's the case but if they want to go
out and sign someone
they they uh
you know they're not going to want to
wait around for tom brady to make a
decision unless they decide to you know
there's a chance that tom brady causes
the whole process
because of the importance of the
quarterback position maybe everybody who
has a shot at tom brady
just just tables everything you get a
moratorium on all quarterback contracts
until brady picks a team
i mean anything's possible mike and and
it's also possible
that
you know by brady picking a team
it's possible to me
that that only exacerbates the process
because what happens if he picks uh the
las vegas raiders
and and now all of a sudden
that you know if the raiders cannot
convince derrick carr to be a good
soldier and to sit for a couple of years
and i doubt they would anyway they'd
probably just let him go
uh or try to get something from for him
obviously
um
if that happens
then derek carr goes into the pool and
in essence you've replaced one
quarterback who probably is a starter
somewhere
uh derek carr
with
another quarterback who's maybe the
greatest quarterback of all time but
that still means that the pool hasn't
been reduced by one it's even stephen
so i i mean there's so many things that
could happen with brady
but even brady signing somewhere
may mean
that there has not been any dilution of
the product of quarterback in 2020.
you know there may be some people out
there saying why are you spending so
much time talking about this guy who's
going to be 43 in august his best years
are behind him look he's still got an
extremely high level of skill and
ability we've seen that he didn't have
the help around him this past year but
he can still play at a high level
he
is
one of the best quarterbacks if not the
very best quarterback in the history of
the game and he's intent on playing for
three more years and wherever he goes
peter the tickets are going to be sold
out the suites are going to be sold out
the jerseys are not going to be able to
make them fast enough this guy's still
one of the top sellers with his jersey
even though every patriots fan who was
ever going to buy one of these damn
things keeps buying them you put him on
a new team can you imagine can you
imagine how many brady jerseys are going
to be sold in the first day
especially if it's the rate like if it's
the chargers okay
i mean people are gonna buy that jersey
if it's the raiders people around the
world are going to buy the jersey
and so my feeling is that and look i
don't know i mean if it's the bucks how
many people buy it versus the raiders i
have no idea and i'm sure tom brady
doesn't give two hoots but
i just think that there are so many
dominoes that could fall i was joking
with another uh pro football writer the
other day i said
do not take a march vacation this year
not do it
uh you know because because your march
is going to be like your january that's
all there is to it it's usually that
okay you work a little bit around free
agency and then you know for a couple of
weeks you you take it easy and then go
to the league meetings but now this time
it's going to be mayhem throughout the
month
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports